germinal sur les écrans 300 salles dans
toute la france à partir de mercredi six
mois de tournage et un budget colossal
pour ce film qui met en scène le célèbre
roman d'emile zola en avant première le
film et montrer aux gens du nord ce soir
à lille nous retrouvons tout de suite
bruno masure bonsoir bruno bonsoir hervé
ben je peux vous assurer que ce n'est
pas le grand soir à halle il ici mais on
n'en est pas loin en tout cas c'est
l'excitation du grand soir françois
mitterrand vient tout juste d'arriver
dans une pagaille indescriptible et que
je ne décrirai donc pas toute l'équipe
du film vient également d'arriver il ya
ici
énormément de monde c'est une avant
première tout à fait à la mesure de cet
événement avec on vient de le voir la
présence tout à fait inédite du chef de
l'état une collection de presse un
double symbole vu le thème du film bien
sûr mais aussi parce qu'on sait on en a
encore parlé aujourd'hui avec les
négociations du gatt l'europe est
engagée avec les états unis dans une
bataille d'image pour la préservation de
notre patrimoine culturel françois
mitterrand n'est pas venu seul de paris
pour cette première projection mondiale
un train spécial tgv avec beaucoup de
personnalité est arrivé et trains tgv
très grande vedette avec a déjà dit
deneuve emmanuelle béart daniel auteuil
beaucoup beaucoup de gens et bien sûr
toutes les vedettes du film depardieu
carmes et miou-miou laurent terzieff
bernard façon judith henry ou encore
jean dauger milo qui est un formidable
chaval et puis un tgv spécial également
pour 400 figurants et leur famille pour
qu'ils puissent participer à cette fête
parce que il faut pas non plus que cette
fête soit réservé au tout état
médiatique et cinéma à côté de moi ils
viennent juste d'arriver un petit peu un
petit peu défraîchi parce que c'est un
véritable parcours du combattant à
claude berri et et renaud claude berri
la première adaptation que germinal a
été signée ferdinand bléka c'était en
1903 et le film dur et à l'époque 15
minutes
on en est loin puisque votre film fait
2h40 peut-être un petit peu plus dans
une version télévision qui devrait
passer sur france 2 qui est coproducteur
de
exempts de ce film dans trois ans alors
on l'a dit on va passer rapidement c'est
le film de tous les records 1328 plan 14
millions est consacrée aux décors et aux
costumes etc
alors petite question simple on voit pas
parler tout le temps argent loin de là
mais est-ce qu'un producteur comme vous
à un sommeil agité à l'avant veille de
la sortie en france d'un film d'un
budget de 165 millions de francs oui
une demi heure je dors une demi heure je
pleure non je rigole non je n'y a déjà
pas mal de gens qui ont vu le puits
monsieur je suis assez optimiste on va
soit on en perdra tout à l'heure il a
été projeté
chez les mineurs cet après midi vous
nous direz l'accueil qu'il a reçu
est-ce que c'est pas que même un peu un
pari un peu fou de faire un film avec un
budget aussi considérable sur un roman
ou chinois he alors que peut-être les
gens justement en période de crise ou en
vie de rêve de s'évader et de ne pas
retrouver sur l'écran pour dire du monde
il faut pas oublier que je suis metteur
en scène d'abord et j'ai la chance
d'être metteur en scène producteur
j'ai eu la chance de faire des succès
comme géo pantin jean de florette où
l'ours moi c'était panique et sur
l'argent j'avais envie de faire germinal
peut-être les jeux réussis peut-être un
petit peu moins peut-être le plus belles
bêtes ils perdent de l'argent c'est pas
le problème
puis voulait faire le fil voilà vous
l'avez fait c'est un peu vous je suppose
que ce soit ou pensez-vous que votre
père c'est lui qui est un peu pour lui
que vous avez fait ce film
alors il ya une petite polémique là
aussi on va pas y revenir c'est pas très
important sur le fait qu'on redonne
l'image de danone un peu passéistes des
mineurs les corons et c'est l'enfer
c'est un film sur la mémoire ses seins
whip sur la mémoire sur ce qui s'est
passé entre le livre et le film et les
réflexions qu'on puisse se faire
bien entendu sur le passé et sur ce qui
s'est passé au xxème siècle sur ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui je ne pense pas que
ce soit une passéiste on en parlera
quand on leur a vu alors dans un instant
et chrono on va parler de votre folle
journée parce que vous êtes allé
retrouver vos amis mineurs la langue en
pas de calais toute cette journée
auparavant c'est vrai on l'a dit les
peut-être l'aigu vraie vraie grande
vedette de ce film ce sont les figurants
il ya eu sauf erreur à peu près dix
mille cachée de figuration c'est pas des
figurants 1 c'est le coeur du film comme
celui-là je précise
c'est pas des figures là et donc dans ce
coeur du film dans tous les sens du
terme
il ya beaucoup d'anciens mineurs
donc qui ont revécu on en a autour de
nous ici donc dans cinq mineurs qui ont
revécu à l'occasion de ce tournage une
période difficile mais aussi très
nostalgique je vous propose de voir tout
le reportage d'eric terrain et de pas
qu'on voit dans le film ils sont bien
plus que des visages des silhouettes
parce que les personnages qu'ils
interprètent les mineurs de germinal
sont leurs grands parents parce que
beaucoup d'entre eux ont 20 30 ans de
fonds et le tournage a été comme un coup
de grisou dans les mémoires
les larmes le vent sec qui souffle sur
la mine d'arenberg ne les a pas séché à
quelques dizaines de mètres du tournage
certains reviennent aux puits où ils ont
travaillé jusqu'à ce jour de 1989 où les
houillères ont fermé le site
quand la mémoire car est ce qu'on n'est
plus qu'un souvenir
rambert en 89 et à les garder en
souvenir qu'on ne s'y trompe pas
nostalgie certainement mélamine a laissé
des traces blessure accident silicose le
travail au fond était rude et quand on
regrette les fermetures c'est souvent à
cause d'un autre danger le chômage moi
je me souviens j'avais des copains qu'il
disait toujours qu'on puisse n'djamena
faussement je me coupe les oreilles si
malafosse et maintenant qu'est ton
chômage s'il y avait une fois ci dira l
écoute mon garçon puisque était pas
capable dans les arrières
ce tous ces anciens mineurs voulaient
participer c'est qu'il savait que le
film serait un hommage à leur métier au
monde ouvrier
ceux qui l'ont retrouvée sur le tournage
c'est peut-être ce qu'il regrette le
plus et qu'ils portent en eux l'amitié
et la chaleur alors vous avez passé une
nouvelle fois aujourd'hui une journée
avec vos amis mineurs à ce qu'aucun
ouvrage vous avez vous allez trouver
sous les cadeaux oui c'était mon musée
de la mine la maison commence à
s'enrichir sérieusement j'ai on a vécu
avec l'autre des moments d'émotion
exceptionnel on avait vraiment tous les
deux les larmes plein les yeux et de
l'émotion plein de coeur on est allé au
syndicat des maisons du syndicat des
mineurs de lens où nous en remise à
titre honorifique la médaille d'or qui
remettent aux mineurs qui ont reconnu
qu'ils ont vécu ce 50 ans de combat
syndical nous ont offert cette médaille
à claude et moi les mineurs du nord pas
de calais à renault et à claude des
travailleurs de la terre syndicat des
travailleurs de la terre alors je les
accepte et en mémoire de mon grand père
qui a travaillé la terre qui a été
mineur et c'est un peu pour lui que j'ai
fait ce film mais c'est surtout pour eux
pour essayer d'être comme indigne de de
la passion l'entousiasme de la folie la
démesure et 2 de l'amour que berry a mis
de gants sim et puis c'est bien sûr pour
tous les mineurs et pour tout pour tous
les gens qui qui pensent encore que les
mots justice solidarité fraternité ont
un sens vous est prévu en principe à
fait comme comme on dirait on si tu es
taux d'intérêt comme un garçon un
guadeloupéen et le fait que nous
présentons la république lui-même se
soit déplacé ça doit encore augmenter
votre votre stress et votre trac non ben
ça ap au moins une grande valeur de
symbole c'est pas un film c'est pas
n'importe quel film c'est pas c'est pas
un succès un sujet universel et éternel
la lutte désespère contre les nantis et
le président soit là ça fait très
plaisir
alors vous avez beaucoup hésité avant
d'accepter ce rôle pendant des mois
sinon des années maintenant vous n'avez
plus aucun regret maintenant que le ça y
est c'est parti je le regrette pas avoir
été aussi bon que j'aurais voulu
mais claude est content j'attends le
verdict du public
claude est content au point qu'il envie
de repartir dans une nouvelle aventure
avec moi ça reste du domaine du projet
mais moi je suis partant aussi les yeux
fermés des petits accrochages on l'a
beaucoup raconté aussi bon il y avait
c'est normal on s'est un peu engueulé
sur le tournage mais maintenant tout ça
est oublié qui tout ça va démarrer donc
mercredi 300 salles une dernière
question claude berri pour parler de
choses sérieuses et politique même au
vrai sens du terme en ce moment on
discute des accords du gatt moi il ya
deux grands films cette année il ya le
vôtre et il ya jurassic park est ce que
vous y voyez un symbole vous alors que
le cinéma français est parti dans une
lutte de défense de son identité si je
puis dire on va parler énormément de la
médiation autour de germinal bien sûr
les gens qui ont critiqué la médiation
moi je dis tout de suite j'ai quand les
médias n'ont pas envie de s'intéresser à
vous pourrez faire les pieds au mur vous
les avez pas alors je dirais que la
lutte d'un côté de germinal et de
l'autre côté jurassic park
il ya d'un côté la médiation du contenu
et de l'autre côté il ya la médiation du
marchandising voilà très bien alors je
rappelle c'est peut-être le moment de
dire que ce film n'est pas interdite aux
mineurs loin de là qu'il sort qu'ils
sortent donc 300 salles c'est ça
mercredi
donc évidemment vous serez un peu
fébrile vous attendez au moins cinq
millions de spectateurs et vous avez dit
que j'attendrais tous ceux qui viennent
ou un jus qui viendra et puis si ça
marche vous allez vous payer un vidéo
car on est encore plus beau que celui de
coppola c'est ça s'était présentée il
est déplaisant hockey en tout cas avant
je vais vous laisser aller assister à
cette avant première avec le président
et puis toutes les vedettes du film en
souhaitant un succès majeur à ce film
sur les mineurs merci beaucoup nous
avoir consacré quelques minutes avoue
hervé merci bruno merci renaud et merci
claude berri et tous les comédiens du
film germyn